we're going to do a silly one today
we're going to talk about a special
number we like doing videos about
special numbers and we're gonna do a
prime because we do love our prime
numbers as well it's quite a big prime
number so I'm gonna write it out so it's
going to start 357 six Tilian so it's
already going to be big 686 quintillion
312 quadrillion 646 trillion 216 billion
567 million six hundred and twenty-nine
thousand one hundred and thirty-seven so
it's a massive 24 digit prime number but
this is why it's special because if I
remove the first digit the three from
that number the remaining number here
starting with the five is also a prime
number and if I do that again if I
remove the five the remaining number
starting with the seven is also a prime
number and that will be true all the way
down so up to here 629 thousand one
hundred thirty seven is a prime number I
can remove the digit the next number
will be trying all the way down to seven
so it's always trying when I truncate
from the left so it's got a left
truncate able pry and are finitely many
of them and that is the largest one and
I learnt this from my friend Rob east
away who has been on numberphile he's a
mathematician as well and he gave me
this pencil with the number written on
it
there is the number printed on the
pencil so no matter how much I sharpen
this pencil I'm always going to have a
prime number which I think it's wise
written on the other side of this pencil
there you go always in our prime it's a
kind of a joke kind of a joke so this is
a left from K table prime let me show
you how you can create them because
they're not that hard to create so let's
start with the last digit so the last
digit could be you know 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
or 9
my last digit could be any of the
but it has to be Prime as well because I
want a Prime at the end so wine is not a
prime - we could have a prime - at the
end but that's not going to be able to
be extended very much we could have
three as a prime number at the end four
we're not gonna have at the end five
could be at the end six no not a prime
seven maybe eight not a prime and nine
it's not a crime so it's going to have
to end with one of these numbers but
let's just try now to extend it back so
we're going to extend it back to the
left and make a two-digit number let's
go with the seven okay let's make a
chain here let's go from the seven well
then if I extend it it's going to be
either 17 or 27 or 37 47 or 57 or 67 or
77 87 or 97 so which of these are prime
17 is a prime 27 that's not prime 37 is
prime 47 is prime 57 is not 67 is prime
77 that's not a prime 87 is not a prime
97 is a prime so let me just do a couple
more steps let's go from the 47 and
extend that further back 147 perhaps or
two four seven three four seven nine
four seven and we keep extending this if
we want to let's find a prime on that
list so nine four seven is a prime I'll
go like extend that back another step so
this could be one nine four seven
perhaps four to nine four seven oh nine
nine four seven I'm gonna extend another
step here I'm gonna go from this number
I know this is a prime so I'm going to
go from here next try and extend that
back just do another step so this is
three nine four seven 3947 so that could
now be one three nine four seven or two
three nine four seven nine three nine
four seven I'm going to stop at this
step because if we do the checking
through none of these are prime this one
three nine four seven is not a trying to
three nine four seven is not a prime
three three nine four seven not a prime
to prime none of these are primes so the
chain stopped the chain is terminated so
the last prime we had there in that
chain was three nine four seven so
that's the end point for the chain that
we had a number of endpoints that you
can make just doing this kind of method
there's one thousand four hundred and
forty two of these endpoints so those
are going to be the largest Prime in the
chain and the largest one of them is
this 24 digit number I've written out
but clearly you can see there are only
finitely many because once you get to an
end point they can't be extended any
further to the left so that's left from
capable primes so we do write to create
a book just to show you the largest one
that's possible I'll show you the
largest right truncated will prime so
this is just a bit of fun really so it's
a silly thing I know however if I used a
different base because this is a base
ten thing I use a different base if I
used a larger base base twelve base 20
or base 100 or something like that then
each step here would have longer lists
and if the list is longer then they're
more likely to hit a prime so you're
going to end up with longer chains you
actually end up with bigger left
truncate of all Prime's if you do it in
a different base or a larger base for
right to incapable primes the biggest
one we have is 73 million nine hundred
and thirty nine thousand 133 so now if I
start removing digits from the
right-hand side we will always have a
prime if I allowed one to be a prime we
could have a larger number we could have
this number one billion nine hundred and
seventy-nine million three hundred and
thirty nine thousand three hundred and
thirty nine so this is a prime number
and if we remove digits from the right
we always have a prime number but we end
up with one and one isn't a prime number
so I don't know why I even mentioned it
let's have a look at left and right to
incapable Prime's is there primers on
both lists and yes there is the large is
one of those that we can find seven
hundred and thirty nine thousand three
hundred and ninety-seven so that is left
on capable and it's right from
catapulted on both the lists although we
are don't think we can truncate
simultaneously because we're not going
to get prime numbers if we do that
what's the longest you can do
simultaneously
well I is an interesting question
because what about if we can remove the
digits in any order we want four hundred
and fifteen thousand six hundred and
seventy three and I'm gonna delete not
just from the ends I'm going to delete
the one yeah it's gone so I've got this
number now forty five thousand six
hundred and seventy three and that's a
prime number now I'm going to delete
another digit I will delete the three
for this one so now I've got four
thousand five hundred and sixty-seven
now if I've got that I'm gonna delete
the five in this case to get four
hundred and sixty seven which is a prime
and now I'll delete the four so to make
67 which is a prime and now thing I'll
delete the six to get a seventh okay I
create this chain of primes but I'm
allowed to delete the digits anyway I
want so those are called deletable
primes and it is thought that there are
infinitely many of those but that is
something we don't know because we
haven't proven that to be true so that
is a challenge
what's the number you could create a
deletable prime where it doesn't matter
what digit you delete any digit you
delete will still leave you with a prime
number that's another that's another
good idea and I don't know if they exist
that would be interesting to find out
good to work Oh me from past experience
I can imagine some people might be
thinking what's the point of all of this
why study these truncate Abul primes and
deletable primes
well first I'm not in tightly sure there
has to be a point sometimes things can
just be fun but I think there is a bit
of a point too and let me explain
studying problems like this things from
completely out of left field make you
think differently they make
mathematicians come up with new tools
and ideas and thinking differently
thinking about problems you don't
normally think
about is really good for your brain it
makes you smarter and this is where
today's episode sponsor brilliant come
in brilliant is a website full of
quizzes and puzzles and courses and
they're all things that come out of left
field they make you think differently
you can't rely on the equations or the
principles you learned at school they
challenged you and they make you smarter
now if you go to brilliant org slash
numberphile you can check it all out
there's lots of stuff for free but if
you use the slash numberphile URL a
they'll know you came from here and B
you can get 20% off their premium
service which unlocks loads of extra
goodies on the website
our thanks to brilliant for supporting
this episode